[Music]
apparently there are about 80 million
fans of trumps Twitter because that's
how many followers yeah I don't they're
fans they're more like let's watch this
[ __ ] train wreck you have to follow
Trump right
if you I like NASCAR accidents it's fun
to watch it's a trainer I like the mean
well on not the bad ones
the mean Trump what's that mean Trump
you're talking a fake Trump 100 right
right right
he always says what Trump might have
said or whatever you know what I'm
talking about I think I do follow Trump
on Instagram though I don't know if it's
is it him I don't even know only this is
reposts where do you follow do you even
know what the [ __ ] you guys do you play
for Kanye oh yeah carnies posted online
there we go
about the same messaging there there you
go but then you know what I saw how many
followers like Obama had and I'm like
dang Obama's were popular had it was way
bigger yeah that makes sense yeah so
there's a lot of people that also hate
Donald Trump obviously I hadn't heard
that yeah your dear first name was but I
yeah
Trump is notorious for his antics on
Twitter we all know that and recently he
posted something about how Mahlon
ballads leads to fraud for elections
maybe I heard about that no I'm the only
one I knew was the [ __ ] he calling
everyone thugs that are protesting oh
we're talking about that today too
yeah but for this one we're singling out
one particular tweet because this
started a firestorm for him because
Twitter fact-checked his tweet which was
saying claiming that mail-in ballots for
elections lead to fraud and historically
all elections do mail-in ballots so
they're like that doesn't make any sense
what you're claiming so they basically
took it down and then now Trump is
trying to sign an executive
of order to basically have a [ __ ]
tweet show up on Twitter yes protect to
protect crams be free speech and not let
these companies dictate what should be
up or not well on so social media
companies have like they had Congress
carved out a bunch of laws for them
where they can't be sued for defamation
for a lot of things and and because
they're considered I don't know I don't
want to even call it but the idea behind
it is basically Trump is taking that
away because they have integrated
themselves into the political price
there's a law that I think was passed in
96 that pretty much protects all
internet-based companies and everything
online so there's free speech whatever
and the law cannot touch these companies
which then has now led to a lot of tech
companies to take it into their own
hands to monitor and to censor and
whatnot and so Trump saying we shouldn't
let these private companies had that
kind of power and we should put this
power back into the government is pretty
much what they also fact-checked him
frankly with sources that are biased
against Trump like like and by that I
just mean like literally one of the guys
who was talking about mailing fraud he
was
his to own Twitter feed I'm sorry the
guy one of the guys who censored him
from Twitter his own Twitter feed is
like super anti Trump the whole [ __ ]
way so like you know and also mail-in
ballots ballots have had issues in the
past with fraud and how do you confirm
that these are legitimate people without
I don't know I don't think there is a
way because yeah I mean I feel like the
Internet has always been though like the
wild wild west especially with the
recent experience or Equifax hack you
can basically use that database and vote
however you want and do a lot of
identity theft and all that is it like
jury duty style like where whatever like
your DMV or whatever ID them address
your register to they send the ballot to
your house there mm-hmm to try to yeah
this way they can kind of cootie right
this side this new idea is that
basically it would be everyone's voting
from ballot via mail because of
coronavirus concerns and so people are
saying that that could be a real rife
with abuse if it gets in the wrong hands
people printing ballots up yeah people
claiming that certain people are voting
even though they're dead which all the
government that's gonna send to you to
fill out they're scared that people are
gonna start printing their own ballots
yes they could to the earth there's just
different ways that people can like
signing the numbers can fraud the system
in their own county right because the
thing that Obama even said about our
elections if you remember in 2016 he
said well our elections are
decentralized so you're not gonna have a
big problem with fraud with voting but
you you still have your regularities
with votes and Obama wasn't even saying
that doesn't happen that's the problem
they uncover like voter fraud during the
bush election when with Diebold right
the the electronic voting machines were
kind of [ __ ] up Diebold was the
creator of that of those machines and
those machines were shown to be to be
[ __ ] with yeah so you know I'm always
skeptical of all voter fraud [ __ ] so
just because it's Trump saying it
doesn't mean that we shouldn't listen to
it like [ __ ] we should be vigilant so
you then so then let me see if I'm
following correctly so he puts out this
tweet it gets censored because Twitter
it because then people from Twitter are
saying he's just spreading false
information yeah so we can't support
this now he's trying to pass something
so that everything goes up well but but
then but then that the state has the
ability to take the anything down so
it's a mystery about what they don't
know is that what people don't know most
people don't know is that Trump isn't
the first to do this there's a reason
why zugerberg was out there on the stand
it's because there's a battle going on
right now and the question is is
Facebook and all these companies are
they like you know AT&T is it like a
phone service is it a place where people
can be free and say whatever or is it a
place that need to be regulated so this
is also why we're feeling the effects on
YouTube and
Instagram and all that where there's a
fellow over that forms there's over
control right now right because what my
insider friends in these companies are
telling me is that they're trying to get
ahead of the problem so we all want free
speech and we don't want the censorship
but here's the thing it's like if the
government comes in and controls these
companies and how they're managed right
that's gonna be a whole nother set of
problems for the rest of us that's the
assumption of like Facebook and what
what what not right so they're like I
rather self-managed before I have to
jump through these hoops and loops when
the government comes in and tries to do
all this stuff that's true so they're
trying to get ahead of the game and
we're seeing the effects of that of like
maybe we made an incorrect post because
they just don't have enough staff to
help us out so the [ __ ] algorithms
and whatever we're a victim to that so
it's just the whole chaotic situation
right now
and the crazy part too is Facebook and
Twitter are kind of at odds with each
other too in philosophy because
Zuckerberg is kind of like well in that
in his philosophy he's saying we no one
should touch this this should be a
free-for-all like it should be a public
square
well well Facebook [ __ ] up Facebook
didn't do that though cuz they they out
they banned some people and all that in
and so some guys that if that was his
philosophy he basically is a hypocrite
because I don't I mean obviously I mean
he made the call but he Facebook is
known to take out people that didn't
agree with their political stance on
certain things including groups yeah
they'll just take your group down Wow
and so and also they'll censor your
posts and they'll also fact-check your
post with with with sources that you
know Nessus don't necessarily counter
rebuke or even rebuke your point right
if you actually read the [ __ ]
articles half the time they don't even
necessarily like say oh this is not true
they say this is not true in the subject
but then if you go all the way down they
actually sort of agree with it like it's
not it's not one to one like yes this is
easily debunked like voter fraud happens
mail and voter fraud has happened ballot
harvesting is not necessarily a great
thing which is
so this isn't just a [ __ ] a lot of
people like to do this [ __ ] where
they go the truth has a liberal bias or
the truth has a conservative bias and
the truth is way harder thing to nail
down than just go in it has it belongs
to one party I know you even know what
the truth is I don't you know what my
fix is what it is because if it wasn't
easy fix I think that people won't be
spending years trying to figure it out
right right like there's so many I guess
things that we have to consider such
such as like should the government
control these new entities that we use
on a and they are kind of monopolies
right because you know you have Facebook
and all these other who's there's no
myspace competing with it anymore right
or like there's no Instagram and
Facebook or Facebook owns Instagram so
these these two companies can work
together right it's just like it's it's
you know they have they have a monopoly
what you're saying right and the
craziest part too is they it's not just
these platforms that that may or may not
need regulating there's also just a
darker part aspect of the internet that
obviously on a moral level needs
regulating such as like you know child
porn and all these things but because of
this this this law passed in 96 that the
internet is a pre free for all space
like the government has very little
ability to shut down these things that
are happening on the Internet
so that's another angle to think about
well they can shut you down for whatever
the [ __ ] they want I mean look at
WikiLeaks bro like slightly like and
they really wanted to if they think if
you're against them those are coming at
you what what what disturbs me I have
been a WikiLeaks thing I shut down I
mean they basically threw Julian Assange
in jail and they're gonna extradite in
probably the United States where he's
gonna face trial for basically just
giving us truth about how we've all been
spied on for years but quickly Joe Biden
I don't know anyone who voted for Joe
Biden I think that Bernie Sanders has
got completely [ __ ] hardcore and I
think that we are all pretending like
voter fraud didn't just happen like and
by the way I mean it wasn't it it was
proven that
happened the dnc [ __ ] Bernie over with
Hillary's campaign saying it was working
but it was coordinated not not by not
with ballots they you the influence
inside the DNC and they did the same
[ __ ] again - to Bernie just just again
so or just right now by they basically
put Biden in into place like like nobody
voted for yeah I really want to know cuz
my assumption is that I'm thinking that
boomers who don't go online and they
just watch TV all day they're the ones
that voted and they're I'm assuming that
maybe the reasoning is hey Obama was a
great eight years and he was in office
so he has experience so let's bring him
back in but even then right what did
they do to Bernie they said he's a
Russian agent just before everyone goes
and votes on Super Tuesday so and that
was all proven to be [ __ ] after
Super Tuesday was over so and also they
kept Elizabeth Warren in who was
siphoning off Bernie votes and they all
knew to keep Elizabeth Warren in and
Elizabeth Elizabeth Warren stayed in to
siphon Bernie votes and then as soon as
that [ __ ] was over she pulls out and
it's already too late for Bernie
so we act like voter fraud look I'm not
talking about ballot voter fraud there
I'm talking about influencing elections
nudging the public to only have one
choice is what it is so it's all such a
big scam anyway so the idea that ballots
don't get [ __ ] with yeah right you if
you look back in 2016 I think they
proved something like they said all only
four irregularities happen does anybody
really think that does it be honestly
once a year that's ridiculous
yeah right does anyone want to sit here
and say I think it only four
regularities happen I mean just even if
everything was honorable just human
error can [ __ ] a lot of things
absolutely that's what I'm saying yeah I
don't buy all this [ __ ] ever
it's common sense sometimes
[Music]